j'ai hâte de vous raconter l'histoire
d'aujourd'hui genre c'est un bordel j'ai
besoin d'un partage et psychologiquement
je suis pas bien mais avant ça comment
allez vous passez vous un bon été
profitez vous bien du sol et j'allais
dire mais n'y a pas de soleil blanches
dans cette vidéo c'est la plus
uniquement bref aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter comment un ancien major de
l'armée britannique a décidé de créer
son propre pays sur un fort abandonner
alors évidemment il ya eu énormément de
péripéties on dirait un peu une télé
réalité mais vous allez voir il ya de la
radio pirate du coup d'état de la mafia
russe
bref c'est tout un bordel direction de
la mer du nord à seulement dix
kilomètres de l'angleterre
là où le drapeau rouge et noir de cette
principauté floch toujours commençons
par le début le héros de cette histoire
il s'appelle roj bates roye né en 1921 à
londres où il passe une enfance plutôt
tranquille mais attention relier
l'aiment pas à la tranquillité
lui ce qu'il aime c'est l'aventuré il
aime tellement ça qu'à 15 ans et ment
sur son âge pour aller s'engager en
espagne contre le dictateur franco
on voit pas ce véto à 15 ans montés sur
notre âge pour genre séduire une meuf
plus vieilles ou essayer de rentrer en
boîte dans mon cas j'avais cette tête
sanaa ça n'a jamais marché aimant la
castagne il rejoint tout naturellement
l'armée britannique durant la seconde
guerre mondiale afrique du nord italie
il enchaîne toutes les campagnes
militaires et même s'ils se blessent
très souvent ils continuent d'aller au
front parce qu'ils aiment la castagne et
du coup il devient rapidement major et
vous allez voir que rolls ce trait de
caractère la deux battants il va le
garder pour le meilleur et pour le pire
surtout fin de la guerre rôle se
reconvertit et il ouvre plusieurs
entreprises florissantes dans le domaine
de la pêche sur la zone côtière de
l'essex sa reconversion elle a marché de
malades
il est vraiment excellent en affaires
c'est un très bel exemple pour le pays
mais un jour ron weasley mais il fait un
peu comme john mcafee et se regarde dans
la glace et il se dit et si je pétait un
câble a en gros il en a un peu marre de
son travail quotidien et de mener des
affaires investir dans des entreprises
ça va deux minutes lui c'est un
aventurier est là et la soif d'aventuré
à ce moment là on est encore en plein
dans les années 60 et dans les années 60
la radio elle est au max et en
angleterre la bbc que vous connaissez
tous probablement elle a le monopole sur
toutes les ondes radios du pays
sauf que ce monopole il fait chier les
anglais parce que la bbc elle est très
conservatrice genre c'est des émissions
qui font un peu chier les jeunes c'est
des contenus qui sont pas vraiment en
adéquation avec les nouvelles
générations c'est comme si à la télé
avec eux thierry ardisson serait
terrible ça pour nous les jeunes n'est
ce pas mais face à ça il ya plein
d'anglais de roye qui décident de créer
leur propre radio pirate c'est à dire et
mettre du contenu sur des ondes radio de
manière complètement illégal pour rock
un peu un héros de la guerre c'est un
vrai switch c'est vraiment mal vu
faire ce qu'il fait mais lui il a soif
d'aventuré ils se lancent dans ce truc
de radio pirate faut savoir que les
radios pirates pour éviter de se faire
exploser par la justice
ils ont trouvé une petite astuce très
simple et m en dehors des limites
légales du royaume uni mais suffisamment
proche du royaume uni pour que ce soit
captée par les anglais un truc qui se
fait beaucoup du coup c'est d'émettre
depuis un bateau et un truc qui se fait
un peu moins cd m 2 puis d'efforts
abandonné en pleine mer bien entendu à
la fin de la guerre bat les anglais ont
laissé ces forts à l'abandon et on en a
plus jamais entendu parler jusqu'à
l'arrivée des radios pirates après
attention on dit fort on pense au fort
de fort boyard
non le forum et si c'est ça moi
j'appelle ça une plateforme rouyer qui
plus est bref roj
il a son petit caprice de vétérans il
veut sa plate forme après quelques
recherches il décide de mettre le cap
sur le fort note john qu'un fort proche
des côtes et facile d'accès mais en
arrivant petite déception il ya déjà des
gens sur place
il ya déjà des gens qui sont là
puisqu'ils ont eux mêmes une radio
pirate qui s'appelle radio city mais la
piraterie n'étant jamais finir ' les
dégage tout simplement on sait pas
comment mais il a dégagé radio city et
s'installe donc sur le fort et il crée
sa radio pirate la radio et sexe la
première radio pirate qui émettra 24
heures sur 24 le temps passé forcément
le gouvernement il apprécie pas de ouf
tout ce délire de radio pirate pourquoi
parce que ça fait des sous mais ça fait
des sous pour quoi parce que les marques
elles ont compris que c'était énormément
écouter les radios pirates et elles
commencent à investir ah oui elles
veulent des pubs reuil se fait cramer
évidemment il se fait convoqué devant le
tribunal
et là il prend très très cher s'emballe
d'amande d'accord si ce qu'on paie quand
notre caisse va la fourrière ici ok il
est pays s'en bat les couilles mes
petits trucs relou et l' interdiction
d'émettre depuis fort mais c'est roj
eyrolles il se laisse pas faire on est
en 1966 c'est noël les anglais se
réunissent ouvre des cadeaux et sont
heureux comme tout roj
il ouvre pas de canon croyez vous pensez
à son fort et les vénère du coup après
de longues recherches et découvre un
autre fort le raouf towers les gars il
faut comprendre que rolls il est
vraiment des ter sera la guadeloupe là
on est en plein hiver en angleterre à 10
km des côtes icai de dengue et prend son
bateau direction rove towers et en
arrivant petite surprise il ya encore
deux mecs d'une autre dans l'adieu
pirate radio caroline meyreuil 20 encore
décidé de les dégager prof towers jlt
devient donc le qg de radio et sexe et
ce nouveau fort il a un très grand
avantage
il est pile en dehors des eaux
territoriales anglaise en gros sur ce
fort la justice elle peut quasiment rien
faire après les gars n'oublions pas
c'est pas le luxe c'est une plateforme
de merde roues
et qui fait à peine 500 m² le chauffage
il galère à tenir la cadence
c'est vraiment à chier mais pour roye
c'est sa terre et il veut pas qu'on lui
pique attendez attendez on avait dit
charroi radio caroline mais radio
caroline ses dessins
depuis tout ce temps caché dans l'ombre
il observe un peu le fort le truc c'est
que rome il a quelques affaires à régler
sur la terre ferme va les y retournent
directement
ils font des travaux pour être
ravitaillé plus facilement puisque c'est
un peu galère l'effort puisque principe
d'un fort c'est d'être inaccessible et
puis pendant les travaux il s'emballe un
peu ses escalades et où ils se disent
veut nous faire n'élit pas de faire
atterrir des hélicoptères sur notre
force
les gains ou parle de gars qui font des
radios pirates quoi s'est passé pas
james bond on y apprend que radio
caroline est de retour sur le fort et se
l'est approprié en faisant des petits
travaux il est furax mais cette fois on
sait pas trop comment mais il réussit à
faire copain copain avec radio caroline
avec les mecs qu'il a dégagé trois
semaines plus tôt je sais pas quel genre
de négociateurs sérum et il est
incroyable il arrive à les en fumée et
radio caroline acceptent de collaborer
avec rolls tout se passe bien entre nos
amis radio caroline ça marche bien et un
beau jour
roye est chargé de garder le fort avec
un ami quelques jours plus tard la
relève arrive demande de radio caroline
soit en bas du fort et roye ne les fait
pas monter il est regardé il leur dit
écoutez c'est sa maintenance euphoria
mois royce est vraiment un chien les
gars c'est un truc de ouf
les gars de radio caroline parts sauf
que là évidemment sur la terre ferme il
faut une réunion de crise
et ils se disent attentats temps il nous
a déjà dégagé une fois c'est hors de
question que ça nous arrive une nouvelle
fois c'est mort il décide donc d'envoyer
un bateau rempli d'hommes pour récupérer
la plateforme et devinez quoi en
arrivant sur place ils se font tirer
dessus et ils se prennent des cocktails
molotov
las les hommes de radio caroline
évidemment ils sont en panique et ils
prennent la fuite
et devinez quoi reuil pour fêter cette
victoire il va marquer en gigantesque
son prénom sur la plateforme au cas où
c'était pas clair c'est sa plateforme
voilà il est tellement serein et heureux
sur sa plateforme qui va y ramener sa
femme et ses deux enfants la thur quelle
jeunesse nouveaux problèmes
le gouvernement anglais en a ras le cul
de ces affaires de radio pirate et
décide donc de détruire tout l'effort
autour du royaume uni comme ça plus de
radios pirates
sauf qu'avant de détruire raptors il
faut trouver une manière légale de faire
quitter royer sa famille de la
plateforme le gouvernement tente un gros
coup de bluff sur rails et lui explique
que le fort est la propriété du
ministère de la défense qu'il invite
gentiment à dégager mais quand même il
lui propose cinq mille balles de
dédommagement parce que voilà rôle où il
doit changer domicile quoi super
répondront que diriez vous plutôt de 90
mille balles c'est mieux non
il est très chaud en négociation je
voulais dire c'est un as
alors évidemment le gouvernement
fusent et il envoie tout simplement des
snipers prêt à le déloger mais
finalement au dernier moment il annule
la tentative en se disant que ça va
dégénérer et que ça va finir dans un
bain de sang ça devient un casse-tête le
dossier espèrent de ministère en
ministère tout le monde se renvoie la
balle tout le monde comprend que c'est
un dossier compliqué et personne n'a
envie de bosser dessus c'est chiant mais
pendant ce temps rôle lui il continue sa
petite vie tranquille et il a un pote un
peu bourré qui pour la blague il dit mes
mecs en fait tu pourrais créer ton
propre pays sur cette plateforme
[Musique]
oui le 2 septembre 1967
roj devient prince de la principauté de
seeland
en fait on appelle ça une micro nation
c'est à dire que techniquement si tu
revendiques un territoire que personne
n'occupe ya une sorte de flou juridique
autour de ça mais en gros ça peut passer
ça c'est maintenant un pays un pays qui
va émettre ses propres passeport créer
son hymne national créé son drapeau et
même adopté une jolie devises et marées
et libertas la liberté de la mer et crée
aussi ses propres peindre et sa propre
monnaie boc tant qu'à faire
donc là on comprend que roj il part un
peu en coulis genre c'est peut-être un
peu trop de pouvoirs d'un coup d'avoir
un pays à toi psychologiquement ça doit
être un peu dur à gérer
un jour il ya un bateau qui navigue dans
la zone pour désarmer d'anciennes mines
rôle il prend sa petite carabine hitcher
allait casser voler mon pays
l'année d'après c'est mickaël son fils
qui prend le relais et qui tirent sur un
bateau qui venait juste réparé une bouée
ils ont des réactions un peu extrême et
sont un peu un poil sur la défensive
droit liétout bref les années passent on
au milieu des années 70 et un nouveau
nom apparaît au générique
alexander hacke en bacs un ancien
vendeur de diamants allemand c'est
clairement le méchant dans fut il ya pas
plus cliché accueil bac lui il y croit
dur comme fer à 6 normes en velay un
pays comme ça qui popent au milieu de
nulle part c'est pas commun et ça attire
la convoitise de gens qui sont un peu
plongés dans des histoires louches à
come back il a même tenté d'attaquer
l'allemagne en justice pour perdre sa
citoyenneté allemande et du coup garder
juste son passeport seelandais sa
citoyenneté seelandaise ce qui fait qu'à
partir de là tu peux faire des trucs
illégaux sans répercussion puisque tu
rentres dans un cadre d' immunité
diplomatique
c'est très bancale en fait comme tout
est flou juridiquement autour de ce pays
puisque c'est jamais arrivé on y voit
qu'à cannes bat qu'il est méga des
terres pour faire évoluer à mort seeland
et décide de le nommer ministre des
affaires étrangères on parle toujours
d'une plateforme rouillé au milieu de
l'océan à qadbak rédige donc une
nouvelle constitution et va l'envoyer à
150 pays dans le but qu'elles soient
reconnus parce que sans la
reconnaissance de tous les autres pays
bas 6
on n'existe pas techniquement mais parmi
les pays qui reçoivent cette
constitution il y en a plein qui
prennent le téléphone et qui décide
d'appeler l'angleterre il appelle les
anglais ils leur disent les gars ça va
vous c'est quoi le délire là exactement
de la plateforme qui veut être un pays
là au milieu de l'eau là sauf que les
anglais n'ont aucun pouvoir et leur
répondent écouter les frères on contrôle
rien là bas ils sont en roue libre à
cannes bac continue de se battre pour
que le pays soit reconnue
internationalement sauf que il trouve
que royer sa famille n'y met pas assez
du sien vous sentez la le conflit il va
donc leur tendre un piège en 78 à cuba
qui propose donc à relier sa femme de
venir en autriche pour rencontrer des
investisseurs
un gros le projet c'est de construire
coller à la plateforme un grand casino
luxueux et voire même peut-être à côté
de ça un autre thème la sphère semble
belle et il faut bien faire rentrer de
l'argent est si lente parce que faire
tourner un pays ça coûte de l'argent
même si c'est à temps de s'informer car
alors notre couple princier se rendre en
autriche les sens sur la plateforme leur
fils michael et personnes se pointe
ils sont comme des cons il sent le
guet-apens et il se dépêche de rentrer
en angleterre et il a raison ce qui se
passe sur le plateforme ses nex lebel le
10 août 1978 pendant croyais et sa femme
sont en autriche il ya un hélicoptère
rempli de mercenaires qui se posent sur
la plateforme ces mercenaires évidemment
c'est les hommes de hackle bac et en
arrivant sur la plateforme i capture
michael et le font prisonniers et ils
vont finir carrément par sur débarrasser
vont se [ __ ] sur un bateau sans aucun
moyen de communication direction les
pays-bas allez ciao michael la
plateforme et donc aux mains des hommes
de hakan bac mais vous connaissez rolls
royce est un gars qui a l'habitude de
gérer paisiblement les conflits naissent
pas y prendre l'hélicoptère il le
remplit d'une équipe qu'il a monté et il
débarque sur la plate forme quand je
vous dis que c'est un [ __ ] films de
james bond de cette histoire et
anecdotes je dis pas ça en l'air le
pilote de l'hélicoptère en question
c'est john crewdson un bon ami de la
famille qui a vraiment été pilote
d'hélicoptère pour les cascades dans les
films james bond est ce que c'est bon
pour vous on est le 15 août 1978 et au
petit matin les mecs sur la plateforme
boivent leur petit et profite de la
rouille lorsque d'un coup oui
l'hélicoptère et bruits de coups de faux
tous les hommes de la plateforme se
rendent immédiatement et leur leader un
certain puts est fait prisonnier il est
jugé par le pays six langues n'est ce
pas et il est condamné par le pays si
lente à leur verser 35 mille libre
évidemment il les a pas donc en
attendant de voir venir cette forme et
doit laver les chiottes servir le café
entretenir la plateforme bref ça devient
esclave de sealand quelques semaines
plus tard évidemment cette histoire fait
un peu le tour du pays
des articles qui apparaissent dans la
presse je vous laisse imaginer la gueule
du gouvernement quand ils ont lu les
articles mais le pire c'est que ça
entraîne une crise diplomatique cette
histoire c'est à dire que l'allemagne
apprend qu'un citoyen allemand est pris
en otage sur une plateforme coller à
l'angleterre
il exige évidemment la libération de
leurs ressortissants allemands et il
explique aux anglais que c'est à eux de
s'en charger quoique ça se passe dans
leur [ __ ] de paix sauf que les anglais
sur au ps ils disent aux allemands
écoutez les gars ça fait des années
qu'on essaie de régler cette affaire là
de reuil de principautés mes couilles
on arrive pas c'est pas dans notre
territoire on peut rien faire bref le
gouvernement anglais se sent humilié ils
ont honte et à la fin c'est même pas les
anglais qui vont résoudre cette histoire
de prises d'otages c'est les allemands
qui vont envoyer un représentant de
l'ambassade allemande sur la plateforme
pour négocier la libération de pouce à
partir de là à cannes bac et tous ses
hommes retournent en allemagne et la
famille royale de sealand vie de nouveau
en paix sur la plateforme
les années passent en 97 on retrouve un
passeport seelandais lors d'une enquête
sur l'assassinât de gianni versace bon
en 99
un homme est arrêté pour vente d'essence
contrefaites et après son arrestation
cet homme aurait déclaré qu'il est
consul de seeland et qui plaide donc
l'immunité diplomatique on n'est pas sur
des petits délits on est sur du crime
organisé
en fait y'a pas grand monde qui est au
courant de l'existence de seeland et de
son statut de pays mais parmi ceux pas
grand monde
il ya plein de mafieux et d'escrocs du
coup ils ont tous commencé à s'inventer
une identité seelandaise via des faux
papiers des faux passeports pour ensuite
plaidé l'immunité diplomatique comme le
mec en espagne action naissance vont
vous dire l'ampleur du truc les
policiers ont retrouvé des papiers
seeland et en europe de l'est dans des
histoires de fraudes
il en a retrouvé dans les mains de
trafiquants de drogue au maroc il en
nous retrouver à hong kong où il y avait
un business de faux passeports si l'ondé
ou pour 1000 $ je pouvais en avoir et la
mafia russe a même créé une société
écran grâce à ces passeports seeland et
le business de cette société écran
c'était la vente de tanks d'avions de
chasse et de pièces d'artillerie au
soudan un pays en guerre sous embargo
là on est vraiment dans des trucs genre
extrêmement grave roj michael et toute
la famille royale évidemment ils ont la
haine
il voulait pas du tout tromper dans des
trucs illégaux du coup ils prennent la
décision drastique d'arrêter d'imprimer
des passeports tout simplement et
écoutez c'est vraiment une nouvelle vie
pour oeil et ses enfants calmels
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu en 2007 il
ya pirate bay donc le plus gros site de
torrent du monde qui cherchent à fuir la
justice suédoise est donc à s'installer
sur seeland
ils veulent racheter seeland pour y
mettre leurs serveurs et
du coup invincible légalement bas vous
savez quoi l'offre et 2 millions de
dollars meyreuil regarde pirate bay le
redis c'est non en 2010 si wikileaks qui
cherchent un refuge pour son créateur
qui est dans le viseur de la justice
et encore une fois run refuse alors qui
est devenu la plateforme ce pays pardon
en 2021
bah écoutez la famille bates a réussi à
perpétuer seeland michael est maintenant
le prince de sealand même s'il vit pas à
plein temps sur la plateforme et le pays
continuent de vivoter tranquillement
dans son coin il ya toujours un garde
armé sur la plateforme comme on l'a vu
tous les projets chelou d'investissement
de business bizarre c'est mort
aujourd'hui les rares rentrées d'argent
de silence se font via leur veste avez
regardez moi ça m'a sauvé connaissez
même pas une blague ils ont vraiment un
site de merde tu peux acheter des
goodies des morgues et même un titre de
noblesse pour 50 balles je peux devenir
lord hochart de seeland
waouh on est donc passé d'un pays mega
vénère ajuste une boutique de souvenirs
flottante qui intrigue les gens et
aujourd'hui si l'on ne sait pas loin
d'être devenu un même genre en 2008 ya
red bull qui a fait un événement de
skateboard et ya plein d'athlètes du
monde entier qui se revendiquent de
sealand genre qui disent qu'ils sont
l'équipe de foot de seeland et en 2013
consécration il ya un alpiniste qui a
brandi le drapeau de seeland en haut de
l'everest
voilà les amis c'était l'histoire de
sealand de ce pays créé par un mec
cramer j'espère que ça vous a plu je
trouve que l'histoire elle est vachement
atypique et je laime bien parce qu'elle
finit vraiment bien il s'est apprécié
c'est devenu des gens un peu plus droit
pour après on ne sait pas tout
évidemment aujourd'hui à un compte
youtube seeland ya un compte certifié
twitter et ya vraiment plein de gens du
monde antique sont fans de sealand quoi
extrêmement dixieland est parce qu ils
sont touchés par l'histoire du truc
bref j'espère que vous avez qui fait je
suis toujours à l'affût des petites
histoires à droite à gauche si je tombe
sur d'autres pépites je voulais
rencontrer
prenez soin de vous profitez bien des
vacances c'est sur les tweets en haute
bruche consulat
ma
[Musique]